nous sommes en 1902 après une promenade
dans le jardin du domaine de candé
le corps d'un autre véreux fréquentant
quelques notables locaux et retrouvé
inanimé dans un salon du château qui
parmi les invités du châtelain est
l'auteur du crime mais attention coup du
sort par chance mes amis mon grand ami
le célèbre criminologue alphonse
bertillon se trouvait justement à tours
pour une série de conférences à l'est
sur lesquelles nous nous sommes
retrouvés entre jeu de piste à l'anglais
et polar d'agatha christie les
enquêteurs d'un jour se lance aux
trousses du coupable on est vraiment au
début de l'aventuré pour l'instant c'est
pas trop mais on va trouver il traque
les indices interrogeant les témoins
dans la cour du château et cela pour
prêter main forte aux plus grands flics
de l'époque alphonse bertillon l'enquète
se débrouille nous sous les meilleurs
auspices pour l'instant je l'espère
j'avance petit à petit et et fort
heureusement je suis aidé par tous ces
enquêteurs amateurs certes mais mettrait
très perspicace et je pense que nous
allons bientôt toucher au but de pièce
en pièce les aides de camp de bertillon
arpente le terrain alors forcément il ya
des contraintes vous le voyez dans la
pièce qui est juste à côté nous on a
beaucoup de mobilier qui appartient au
mobilier national donc il suffit de
canaliser en fait les espaces donc là
pour cette deuxième édition s'est adapté
il fait beau une partie des comédiens
une grande partie des comédiens et en
extérieur et on a bien fléché
l'intérieur du château et sécuriser les
pièces fermer certaines salles et après
effectivement c'est facile après 1h30
d'investigation c'est l'heure de vérité
dans le pavillon de chasse transformé
pour l'occasion en bureau de police
criminelle le grand bertillon donne ses
conclusions le coupable est confondu
satisfaction pour certains qui ont visé
juste regret pour d'autres qui ont
manqué de perspicacité
l'enquêtre est donc un métier bien
délicat